What's up guys we are back with another cooking video
Finally I know you guys been wanting cooking videos
I think the last cooking video was the jambalaya video, and that was over a year ago now, but we are back
We are making salmon today
This specific recipe is my wife's favorite recipe that I make it's healthy and it feels and looks a lot
Fancier than it actually is it's very simple to make very fast recipe
I've actually never bothered to name this dish. It's always been hey, baby. Do you want salmon, hey can you make salmon?
We've never actually called it anything so now that I'm here making the recipe video
Let's just call it baked ginger salmon
And trust me fellas if you want to earn brownie points with your lady friends out there do yourself a favor?
Make this dish because this dish has earned me major brownie points with my wife
So take notes, so let's get started with our marinade. We're gonna start with our fresh ingredients
We're gonna have some ginger some garlic and some green onions the ginger
I'm gonna cut it into medallions maybe about like whoa run away piece
Let's do six medallions
So this dish that we're making it does have an Asian inspiration behind it hence
The use of ginger green onions is a very popular Asian ingredient. All right, so once you have her ginger dice it up
Alright, then we got ourselves a bowl here, we're gonna just toss everything we're cutting up into this bowl
Let's move on to the garlic three cloves of garlic. We're gonna mince them just as small
Once we got that chopped up. Bring our garlic in. And speaking of Asian influences on this dish. I noticed that
Asian foods have their own Holy Trinity because in Cajun cooking
There is the Holy Trinity bell peppers onions and celery for Chinese cooking
Specifically, I would say it's garlic ginger and green onions
Let's go with two spring onions chopped off that part. Chop it in half
Stack it
Alright once we got that chopped up go ahead and add our green onions in yeah
Get off my hands. Cool now
We got our fresh ingredients done moving on to the liquids all right so our first liquid will be sesame oil
Next some soy sauce
To add some pop for our marinade we're gonna add some juice of lime
And finally we're gonna add some oyster sauce one tablespoon of this for some sweetness to balance it out with
Some of the soy sauce and the lime juice all right
And let's go ahead, and this is what we got this is our marinade concoction
Let's go ahead and whisk it up real quick. Just get all the ingredients
worked in together
Smells great
Mmm
There we go we got our marinade
I've already washed the salmon we're gonna section it off in portions now the golden rule for making a portion size for salmon
It's the width of your hand so if you can just put your hand down this right here is the proper portion size for salmon
All right what we're gonna do is put them back organize them a bit
2 by 2. there we go and
Uh got this little tail it's not worth much but uh yeah throw it in here anyways. Let's make room for the tail here
we go all right, so now that we got our fish cut up
We're gonna season this real quick with some salt and pepper something very simple now be easy on the salt
Just because we do have soy sauce in the marinade
And some pepper
All right with finally I'm just gonna spoon on the marinade you want to just kind of work it in.
I also forgot to mention that you want to utilize a dish that you can use to bake with you can dress it up and then
Toss it right into the oven look at that
So now we're gonna preheat our oven to 400 degrees Fahrenheit, and we're gonna bake it.
All right
So now after you've put your foil on top to trap as much moisture in we are now ready for the oven
400 degrees here we come
All right so now with big salmon we want to bake this for about 20 minutes
15 to 20 minutes now some people like to eat salmon
Slightly rare if you're going for that slightly rare kind of texture in your salmon
I would aim for 15 minutes, but for me because I don't trust the salmon. It's not sushi-grade. I'm gonna go 20 minutes
I'm going for more of a well-done
but with salmon you have to be very very careful because
You can easily overcook it and when you do overcook salmon and super dry it's almost as if you cook the flavor out of it
It doesn't taste as good anymore so in the meantime while our salmon is baking we're gonna work on
A little garnish that I like to put on top all right, so we're gonna take those leftover green onions have about
Five of them here, and we're just gonna dice it all up
Alright, so once we have it all diced up
Let's go ahead and toss it in our Bowl alright
And we're gonna just season this with a little bit of salt not too much salt goes a long way in this
all right, so next where you gonna start the fire, and then you want to put about like three tablespoons of
I don't know actually about that much
But yeah, we need some olive oil in here now the idea here
is
and this is a trick that my mom taught me when I was a kid we're gonna want to heat this up until it starts
smoking a little bit
And you're gonna be able to see the smoke and once it gets hot enough we're gonna take this and pour right on top of
That green onions that we have over there. I've never seen this done in any other cuisines other than Chinese cooking
I don't know what it's called the only thing I can call it is flash cooking
You know it's like you're not really cooking these green onions
Or simply pouring piping hot oil on top of it and through that heat
It's gonna sizzle, and that's it not too sure you can actually see it in the camera
But I can see that my oil is already smoking. Let's go ahead and bring in the green onions and
We got our hot oil
Let's go ahead and just give this a nice mix
Work in the green onions into the heat try and use your chimichurri or whatever you want to call it
I don't know
Bam done all right so now when you're doing this green onion
Salsa thing you're gonna want to be careful when you're heating up the oil cause I've learned this from experience
I let it heat up for too long. It's smoking but I'm thinking maybe just give it a little bit more
Just get that really really piping hot next thing. I know my entire kitchens engulfed in flames
Not really, not the entire kitchen, but the pan that I'm heating the world on its engulfed in flames
And I'm freaking out. point is the moment it starts smoking take it off the burner
So it doesn't get too hot and actually ignites. That's a scary moment
The moment we've been waiting for oh that smells good
That looks bomb
Put this aside and let this rest so this salmons gonna be delicious
It looks perfect
And it smells great in here right now and add this little garnish on top mmm out of this world but to further
Complement this salmon. We're gonna plate it with some brown rice and some saute'd spinach tonight and
Let's go ahead and whip that up real quick. Add some oil to your wok, and once it's hot enough
We're gonna go ahead and add some crushed ginger
And some crushed garlic
And basically what we want to do is just infuse this oil with the flavors of garlic and ginger
It's optional you can actually take the garlic and ginger out, but I'm gonna keep it in here
Just because I wanna really get that flavor into that spinach
When you're stir frying or sauteing or whatever
You wanna make sure it's as high as the heat as possible
The idea is to flash cook everything.
You don't want it to let it sit in it's own juices and braise for too long.
And go ahead and season it with a little bit of salt
Stir one last time
And there you have it, turn off the heat. Stir fried spinach.
All right, so we're gonna have we start off with a little bit of rice a little pile in the middle
Right on top
Very very garnishing
BAM And we got it there is one happy wife
You have to taste test before the wifey gets home. Salmon is good. Spinach is good. Mm